hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well in the first of
his meditations on First Philosophy Rene
Descartes has a very interesting
discussion about whatever it is that
created us human beings and he begins by
talking about God and then considers
other possible causes and sets out what
the implications of those would be in
terms of whether we can in fact attain
what it is that he's looking for some
sort of body of certain truths that is
truths that we can at the absolutely
certain of not just know through some
sort of inductive process of probability
but be absolutely assured that we've got
right and he begins by talking about God
he says for a long time I've had in my
mind a certain opinion that there is a
God
capital G God do you right who can do
everything and by whom I was created and
produced such as I am as the being that
I am a human being and for many people
that would be a resolution to the issue
would it not they would say oh well
there's a god therefore I can trust all
these other things there are many people
who make their
their views about the truth of things
rests solely on whether there's a god or
not but that doesn't actually get us out
of the problem according to Descartes
because he goes on and he says you know
how do I not know that that God made
things so that there isn't any earth
there isn't any sky or heaven there's no
bodies there's no extension a tendu
that's that's a very important term for
Descartes there's no figure or structure
of things no no largeness or greatness
grondeer no place and that all the same
I would have the sentiment or belief
that all of these things are the case
how do I know that God isn't actually
fooling me like that he says well you
know I mean I could say God wouldn't do
that that sort of thing but how do I
know he says that in the things that I
think I know with the greatest degree of
certitude that he hasn't made me so that
I deceive myself every single time that
I for example add two plus three how do
I know that two plus three is actually
five and not something else and that God
has just set me up in such a way that I
happen to get a consistent result you
know I need to well you know why that
why would God do that he's not worried
about why God would do that at this
point how do I know that's not the case
or he says when I number the sides of a
square
maybe there's actually more than four
sides maybe I get that wrong
consistently or he says when I judge
something even more easy you're right
that that you know I couldn't imagine
something more than that he says well
you know we might say that would be
repugnant to God's goodness and then he
says okay well we'll consider that in
awhile and he does consider that in
of course meditation 3 and 4 and then he
says you know other people would be
quite happy to say that there isn't any
God they would they would rather deny
the existence of a God so powerful than
to think that everything is so uncertain
and so they actually get God out of the
picture so that they can attain more
certainty and he says let's not fight
them right now in fact let's actually
say that they're right and that God is
just a fable God is just something made
up
so what then do they think brought us
into being what would be the origin of
our being and he considers three
interesting examples or possibilities
here he says maybe a certain kind of
fate destined right or some sort of
necessity fatah vitae right we've got
some causal determinism going on here
that has faded from all time that I
would be brought into being as the being
who I am a human being with the certain
capacities that I have you know
Descartes of course would have existed
back in the 17th century as the human
being that he was everybody throughout
all history is the way that they are
this is a metaphysical view that some
people have held saying well there's no
God but at least there is something like
fate or some sort of necessity that that
produces all of these things down to the
particulars and they couldn't be other
than they are ok that's not a problem
that's there's many people who have held
that view throughout history
or maybe it's chance but maybe it's it's
fortune or a certain kind of randomness
you know recombining things over and
over and over again until you get a
certain kind of result that looks like
this and then looks at itself
reflexively like this and that's what in
French is you know as art right chants
or or when we talk about you
you know hazarding a guess we get that
from that that word so now we've got two
possibilities maybe it's all totally
determined or maybe it's like there's
some randomness there and the randomness
stirs things up and they just sort out
the way they happen to do and then he
brings up another possibility which I
think could you know interpenetrate with
with either these a continual succession
and connection of things sweets in
french and liaison connection between
things and and here we should think
about you know causal connections a
causal nexus things following upon each
other and so Descartes is saying how did
I get the being that I have how did I
get the beliefs that I carry with me
wherever I go about you know the
universe and my body and and mathematics
and geometry where did I get all of that
stuff from well either you know it came
about because I observed my environment
and drew some conclusions you know and I
got into here with the capacities that I
have including my mental capacities from
one of these three types of causes or
origins
broadly speaking now here Descartes
conclude something quite interesting he
says that to these these reasons you
know here's what I have to say he says
whether we think there one way or
another
it is certain now notice that he says
it's certain that since making mistakes
and being deceived are a kind of
imperfection the less powerful the
author that they attribute to my origin
the more it would be probable not just
possible but probable that I would be so
imperfect that I would always deceive
myself I would be fooled
continually so what is he saying there
this well the more imperfect the cause
of my existence and and the way I am the
more likely it becomes that I would be
fooled more and more often that I would
never actually arrive at the truth of
things so for example if it's really
just a matter of evolution for you know
human beings to arrive in existence and
have the mental capacities that we do
and we're responding to our environment
and all that maybe if that's the case
and it's not some sort of you know
transcendent creator God who created us
maybe it's actually more likely that
we're going to get things wrong
continually get them wrong in ways that
have an evolutionary you know advantage
but are still wrong I mean here
Descartes actually sounds like Nietzsche
several centuries later
does he not so what would be the result
of this whatever I'm going to believe in
as the origin of my own being it could
all fool me it could all create me in
such a way that I might get things wrong
continually whether I want to or not
so then the fundamental question is well
how do I overcome this problem of being
fooled and do I really have any chance
to get things right at all
you